Cottage
a trip on a sailboat in an immersive
virtual experience
[Music]
unlock memories and provide a sense of
calm
please check that you are wearing a mask
or social robots there to assist with
daily tasks hello my name is Leia each
evolution of immersive virtual and
robotic Tech is being designed to help
with an upcoming challenge that Canada
isn't ready for
a surge in cases of dementia
Paul Lee it's a matter of Independence
in 2010 Paul developed vascular dementia
after having a series of Strokes he was
only 57.
for the first number of years I didn't
go to my apartment I walk out in the
street
I literally would run back in
because you'd be scared yeah it didn't
look familiar his life was hell
my daughter had to teach me how to live
but Paul's daughter Victoria lives an
hour away from his Toronto home so he
had to find a way to live with dementia
in a safe but independent way
as technology improved so too did Paul's
ability to do tasks alone
Echo turn off dining room light
I rely on technology to live
the max minder app is specifically
designed for older adults
it's loading up
so there's different categories there's
my day
there's my meds it even shows you it
shows you oh what's that meals activity
oh so it tells you you have to eat at
this time yeah you just had your lunch
so you're ahead of Max minder yeah
so now when he leaves home his daughter
doesn't have to be with him an app
called 360 allows her to keep track of
him while he's out for a walk or running
errands if I stop at a certain place too
long then she'll call me you still look
like you still have that look in your
eyes wow and Paul's experience is
important for all Canadians because the
majority of those living with dementia
about 61 percent live in a home setting
and not in long-term care or a nursing
home
thank you
so this is the home lab this is where we
do a lot of our development of different
Technologies
this lab is part of the age Well Network
hundreds of researchers across the
country committed to developing Tech to
help Canadians age at home safely
technology is really starting to have an
increasing role that can provide care
provided support and assistance to
people with dementia in their own homes
and then we have other researchers that
are working Alex mihalides is the
scientific director and CEO of age well
people with dementia even quite severe
cases can continue to remain their own
homes and communities and continue to
participate in their daily lives
in the home lab Alex and Toronto Rehab
Institute researchers have developed
everything from apps apps smart home
systems and even AI
so if you look up here this is an
example of some prototypes that we
developed around automatic fall
detection systems this is really to
overcome the issue with current devices
which typically are pendant that players
needs to wear push their button on the
on their own and then they're connected
to a live operator around 80 85 percent
of people don't wear them and even
beyond that ninety percent of people who
do wear them in Fall don't push the
button because again a lot of them see
it as a one-way ticket out of their home
into long-term care Alex adds that
another reason why people don't like
wearing pendants is due to stigma so he
hopes this prototype will be a more
practical solution for older adults with
cognitive decline at some point because
of the increasing numbers of older
people increasing prevalence of dementia
everyone is going to be touched by this
disease in some way
so he hopes the latest advancements in
dementia related Tech can be available
to everyone as consumer products I would
say in the next three to five years
you're going to see these on the
marketplace
for example for testing the robot we'll
be up here watching and for Alex it's
also personal when he first took on this
role it was about research and
advancements since then his own mother
has been diagnosed with early cognitive
impairment
I've gone from researcher to caregiver
and that's greatly has been informing my
own work it's these personal experiences
that really keep us going and I think
personal experiences that drives I would
say the majority of people within the
age wall Network
[Music]
but the University of Toronto Social
robots are built and programmed to help
older adults
hey my name is it's a really exciting
time to be in robotics there's a lot of
opportunities in terms of development of
of robots to support people we're right
now Paving the way of this emerging
technology yay time to get started
runs the lab she's a professor in the
department of mechanical and industrial
engineering the idea is that we can
design these robots to support cognitive
intervention social interventions as
well as helping people in their everyday
life
do you have chills cough shortness
interaction is key a social robots can
assist those living with dementia they
communicate the same way you and I do
with each other they use facial
expressions gestures and speech to
assist people in their everyday life
whether at home or in a more traditional
Care Facility robots help to prompt and
remind like how to get ready it would
make me happy if you put your right arm
through your button-up shirt or with
physical activity
foreign
their research shows that robots and
users have a high success rate and
robots can help break down barriers
looking good enjoy the dinner today we
want to be able to have Fair access to
technology no matter where you are in
the country as well as we have diversity
and cultural backgrounds so we've had
our robots speak different languages
thank you you may go inside have a great
day goodbye
in Hamilton Ontario there is an
Innovative care home built with
technology and design as the focus
mefia Al matawali's background was in
engineering the former University
professors path changed after his mother
was diagnosed with dementia prior to
this journey I have no idea even what
dementia means and this is the truth I
consider myself fortunate because I went
through this journey hopefully I will be
able with the help and the support of
other to make a difference
so he founded wrestling Gardens a care
home in his mother's honor
TV fireplace while building the facility
nephea researched what would make life
easier for the residents
one of our sweets he gave us a tour
their testing specialized lighting to
help residents feel awake and active
during the day which will help with
quality sleep at night so I can change
the temperature of the light I can
change the intensity
and specialized games to help with
memory and movement
[Music]
just across from the public park he's
also working with the city of Hamilton
to establish a Wi-Fi network in the 49
acre park across the street so residents
can roam freely and be monitored safely
nephea's goal is to advance care for
other families by determining what works
and what doesn't he's also dedicated an
office on site for the Alzheimer's
Society we don't have the cause and we
don't have a cure so what we are trying
to do is to step into the unknown and
that is a research and hopefully from
these experiences we will be able to put
together the care that The Residency and
Canadians need because you're right
you're adding more to these devices in
Whitby Ontario this Mental Health
Hospital offers Specialized Care for
patients with dementia and the team is
gathered to discuss the latest tech
they're evaluating
provide Dr Amer burhan is a geriatric
psychiatrist and physician in Chief at
Ontario Shore Center living with
dementia is a complex situation where
people lose their skill they don't lose
it all at once but as the illness
progresses we know that there'll be more
and more complex needs that we hope
technology will support with
okay
started they teamed up with Ontario Tech
University to innovate and Test new
approaches and tools to help caregivers
and those living with dementia
in the living lab they're evaluating VR
headsets where patients can engage in
reminiscence therapy
the power is that it can be programmed
for each person
this takes it to the next level okay Ron
Baleno knows it would make a difference
he cared for his late father Rey who had
Alzheimer's for more than a decade the
ability to kind of put on some kind of
goggles or something so that he could
actually feel and see let's say what
it's like back in the Philippines you
show them a photo of the Philippines the
sounds of the water and all that he's
going to start talking for about half an
hour to an hour about you know the
Philippines and there's a little bit of
a cultural caregiving piece here
and for those who may not be comfortable
with a headset they can always be
immersed in this 360 virtual reality
room
some common symptoms of dementia are
agitation and aggression
this wearable device monitors things
like body temperature and pulse rate
which could predict the signs and
symptoms that may precede an episode
Dr burhan hopes that the work being done
here will translate outside of the walls
of this Center helping Canadians who are
living at home with dementia
I think the trick is to be able to think
about what is needed co-design it with
people who are involved and then look at
technological solutions that are
suitable implementable upscalable